charity food handouts in the Paris
suburb of Clichy soup wah many people
here lost work during the lockdown and
without money coming in they'd struggle
to feed their families this is really
helpful because the cost of food these
days is so high the French government is
easing the lockdown after two months but
for some people here the worst is far
from over the lifting of the lockdown
will be difficult for some people
because many haven't been able to pay
their bills or rent during this time and
some landlords may evict them the end of
the lockdown also presents challenges
for teachers many schools will remain
shut as some principals worry that
getting children to socially distance is
nearly impossible schools that open will
do so partially and with strict safety
measures across senior tourists Haiti be
done less christine each teacher will
have to wear a mask and i have ordered
some face shields despite the new
regulations and risks as Salima azuz is
looking forward to welcoming customers
again in her fashion shop in Paris masks
will be compulsory and she'll have to
steam clean any clothes that her clients
try on no I think business will be slow
for a while many customers are still
working from homes others are scared to
take public transport there are no
tourists these days profits will be down
by 50 percent this month the French
government will leases lock down in
phases so not all businesses and
services will open on May the 11th in
fact many of them will have to remain
shut including bars cafes and
restaurants in the picturesque
southwestern town of La Rochefoucauld
this restaurants owners had no idea when
they'll be able to open and in what
conditions they worried that social
distancing rules will dissuade people
from eating out thank you I think at the
start people will be scared to come even
our regulars social distancing is hard
in a restaurant sometimes we have 20
people here for coffee and they come in
to have contact and be sociable
it's clear they're trying to revive the
battered economy and avoid a second wave
of infections won't be easy the
government says it'll continue to ease
restrictions if all goes well
but if corona virus infections rise a
new lockdown could be on the table
Natasha Butler al Jazeera La
Rochefoucauld France